the race to contain a new covet 19
variant countries are closing their
borders reimposing travel restrictions
and quarantine measures a clear sign the
pandemic is far from over but are
governments prepared to deal with the
ever-changing virus this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
daddy nabogeta so just as countries
around the world were starting to reopen
their borders and lift covet 19
restrictions a new variant is now
threatening to derail the progress of
the past few months
several nations have already imposed
travel restrictions to and from southern
africa that's where the latest variant
was first detected the world health
organization says it poses a high global
risk
so governments have been put on notice
be prepared
little is known about the new strain but
there are fears it may be highly
infectious and more resistant to
vaccines more than two years since the
start of the pandemic it shows no signs
of ending health officials are urging
nations to speed up their vaccination
drives
we'll bring in our guests in just a
moment but first here's more from the
head of the who who's urged countries to
work together to fight the pandemic
we understand and support every
government's responsibility to protect
its own people
it's natural
but vaccine equity is not charity
it's in every country's best interests
no country can vaccinate its way out of
the pandemic alone
the longer vaccine inequity persists
the more opportunity this virus has to
spread and evolve in ways we cannot
predict
nor prevent
let's not bring in our guests joining us
from cambridge in the uk is dr dipty
gurdasani who's a senior lecturer at
queen mary university of london in addis
ababa dr ahmed aguel uma the deputy
director at the africa centers for
disease control and prevention
over in oxford michael jacobs is the
professor of political economy at the
university of sheffield in the uk a warm
welcome to you all thanks so much for
joining us on inside story dr gurdasani
so just about a year ago when
vaccinations started rolling out the
belief by some was that life could
certainly return to normal just when
things seemed to be looking up infection
started increasing again in some
countries as you know and now we have
this new concerning variant are you
surprised by this or did you expect this
to happen
no i'm not at all surprised in fact a
lot of that rhetoric has come from
politicians particularly in the west
where the idea has been let's live with
the virus and return to normal
scientists have been warning for a while
that that's not possible with a virus
that's been adapting continuously
towards becoming more transmissible
potentially more severe and more able to
escape vaccines so this weight was
entirely predictable because we've had i
think a new variant arise almost every
three to four months and this is
sort of right on time with predictions
that many people have made unfortunately
we've been largely ignored by
governments who
want life return to normal but aren't
really taking steps needed to ensure
that variants don't continue to arise in
the way that they are
michael jacobs i see you're nodding
along um what's your take on this
i think i i bow to the scientific
experts
it is pretty clear that
with a coronavirus that is mutating so
rapidly the ones that will emerge are
the ones that are more transmissible and
more resistant to the vaccine that's
what that's why they emerge um and this
does mean i think that until the world
is fully vaccinated we are going to have
to live with it in the sense that we're
not going to be able to go back to
normal this is the new normal
and so a world of at least wearing masks
physical distancing restrictions on
travel i think is inevitable for several
years yet and the really worrying thing
is the world has not made a huge amount
of progress in vaccinating uh entire
populations you know most european
countries have about 70 percent uh fully
vaccinated now
uh in the uk in the us it's less than
that it's more like 60. most african
countries it's still under five percent
the south africa where
this new variant uh seems to have arisen
is only 25 despite being a richer
african country these levels of
vaccination make it inevitable that we
are going to see this uh virus across
the globe and that will continue to give
us huge economic disruption and huge
increases in poverty all right all
important points which i'll address in
just a moment but first let me bring in
ahmed oguel oma from addis ababa sir
omicron has been classified as a variant
of concern as you know
what is the data available so far tell
us about its infection risk and will it
become the dominant strain do you think
or is it too early to say so
um no thank you for having me let me
start by
correcting the previous speaker
who was alluded to
omicron virus having been
coming from south africa that is
incorrect
the correct position is that it is
impossible
to know where a variant
fast appears
the more efficient scientists are the
ones who are going to be declaring that
they have
characterized a particular variant and
that's what south africa indeed botswana
have done it is the efficiency of their
system that is now being turned around
to label
this particular variant as something
that has happened in southern part of
africa
um let me
shift to your question we don't know a
lot about this particular variant
but the fact of the matter is
we know we expected from the very
beginning that we are going to be having
different variants
that is the way viruses are
they are going to mutate over time so it
is not a surprise
what is surprising is
the panic that we are seeing across the
globe by the time a virus
a new variant has been characterized it
has been circulating
um within the globe
and it is very difficult to then try and
close doors and
pretend that
it may not come into one particular
community um what we need to do
is to understand what this new variant
is all about we still don't have enough
information to do that
and then we react appropriately and the
appropriate reaction
is to use all the tools at our disposal
vaccines is just one of them we must go
back to all the other tools public
health measures masking up sanitizing
providing the correct information and
not panicking so that we can stay ahead
of this pandemic otherwise if we panic
it will always be ahead of us so okay um
is this then
the new normal as you speak of
sanitizing mass squaring
vaccines are people just going to have
to learn how to live
with lockdowns and restrictions and
vaccines and screenings for the
foreseeable future
what what is definitely going to happen
is
um we are going to be living in an
environment that is different from the
pre-pandemic base there is absolutely no
doubt about that we can however be able
to bring this to
a stop if we act together
i'm acting on our own individual
countries communities is not going to
to stop the pandemic
this is a global problem and we must
approach it from a global perspective
where each and every tool is available
to each and every part of the world then
we can be able to bring this to a stop
and some of the restrictions will then
be able to be
removed but so long as we continue
to look at this from
very nationalistic spectacles we are not
going to have it end and any new variant
that will come is not going to be able
to be contained in one country or one
region it will spread so we must act
together so that we can be able to
remove
these restrictions and continue with
life
relatively more comfortably than it is
now dr gurdasani is that something you
agree with also the president of south
africa himself described the emergence
of this new variant as a wake-up call
call for the world
regarding particularly vaccine
inequality and he warned that until
everybody was vaccinated then more
variants were actually inevitable so
with countries and populations having
different access to vaccines as we know
is he right
yes i mean frankly this has been obvious
from when the pandemic started i mean
you need a globally coordinated approach
of progressive elimination this is not a
virus that you can live with because as
i said you will see new versions of this
virus emerge each one potentially worse
than the previous but you don't just
need a coordinated vaccine strategy so
definitely there needs to be global
equity there's no doubt about that and
there's also no doubt that there's been
massive holding of vaccines in the west
that has sort of pushed kovacs to the
end of the queue despite there being a
huge need there but i think there also
needs to be a coordinated effort to deal
with misinformation and vaccine
hesitancy which is impacting i think all
parts of the world including south
africa um and i think unless we have all
of that with a focus on uh you know as
professor emma said every tool in the
toolbox so it's not just vaccines but
high grade masts things that work with
airborne transmission like ventilation
really good surveillance systems we will
not be able to get on top of this so
it's essentially using every layer that
we have and ensuring that there is no
country that's disadvantaged because of
lack of access or shortages or lack of
infrastructure as well as dealing with
the huge amount of misinformation that's
spread across multiple avenues including
social media michael jacobs what do you
think that governments need to do to
manage
this virus in a sort of more effective
way
so we can get back to our
normal lives
well i certainly agree that we need to
be sharing vaccines more equitably
across the world we recently apparently
in the uk destroyed 600 000 vaccines
which had gone past their effective date
which is an absolute moral disgrace and
economic disaster we it is really
appalling that the western countries and
gulf states and others have not been
enabling greater vaccination in the rest
of the world and
as has been said by various leaders
including the head of the who as you
heard earlier
none of us are safe until everybody is
but i also agree that this problem of
disinformation and vaccine hesitancy is
a huge problem in the u.s
it looks very unlikely that they will
ever be able to get to
a a herd immunity because very large
numbers of people almost entirely
associated with supporters of the
republican party do not believe in
vaccinations and in many cases seem to
believe that the whole covet thing is a
hoax now that is a kind of not just
disinformation but a kind of political
war on health and on equity and many
countries around the world see this
where you've got um vaccine hesitancy
bound up with wider mistrust of of
governments of professionals of experts
and so on and this is a real problem
which we have to address in every
country where this occurs right michael
but how difficult is it to balance what
scientists want in terms of wiping out
this virus and what society and
populations need in terms of uh function
and well-being
i think from an economic point of view
it is very difficult there's no question
that as you restrict certain kinds of
contact and travel that certain sectors
of the economy will be heard the travel
industry tourism in particular the un
conference on train development has
estimated that the economic cost across
the world
particularly from the loss of travel and
tourism might go up to four trillion
dollars last year uh and this year so
that is a huge economic cost and it's
obviously much harder for people and
industries where most workers can't work
from home in manual labor sectors
the option of working from home which is
possible for white collar office workers
doesn't exist so this will have is
having a huge economic cost but in the
end
a pandemic which
which we don't get rid of will have a
larger economic cost and so yes of
course this is a balance um some
countries seem to balance this better
than others in other places the
restrictions have been uh have been
minimized because of political
opposition there's a kind of strand of
libertarianism that's definitely true in
my own country in the uk and in the in
the us which sees even things as simple
as mark wearing as incursions on
personal liberty that kind of attitude
is not helping that is making the
situation worse
stand by for just a moment we'll delve
into the economic discussion a little
bit more but take a look at these
statistics so as we mentioned earlier
this new variant is threatening to undo
the recent economic recovery if there
was one millions of people lost their
jobs when businesses were forced to
close during the initial wave of the
pandemic global supply chains are still
severely disrupted as a result of staff
shortages
many ports are clogged with shipments
causing supply shortfalls as well as
rising prices
and the international monetary fund
predicts the cost of food and gas will
rise by 4.3 percent this year and that
is the biggest jump since 2011. um and
on the issue of travel in particular
ahmedabad oma the president of south
africa i'm sure you know has called on
countries which have imposed recent
travel bans on his country as well as
some other regional countries to
urgently reverse their decisions that's
what he says before any further damage
is done to our economies
so knowing that the uk eu and us are
among some of those who've imposed those
travel bans
do you think they're going to make a
difference in fighting this variant
travel bans don't work
we have seen it with and this is not the
first variant that we have faced
uh when we started with the alpha and
the better the delta
um we have very good evidence that
travel bans do not work in fact during
this time of a micro
um
we have seen as of my last account at
least 12 countries have reported
documenting their micron that
variant
so uh closing down economies of um
by by burning travel from one part of
the world to the to another is not going
to help but when you say that you have
evidence i wonder if you can just tell
us a little bit about what that evidence
is
um
look
if you go to each and every type of
variant the only way for you to be able
to know which variant you're dealing
with is to do full genome sequencing
so if a country is doing full genome
sequencing they will be able to tell
what kind of variant they are dealing
with not all countries are doing that
some countries are doing it especially
here in africa we are doing that very
very effectively and when we share that
data we are punished for it second is
when you look at the the way that um the
variants are being
identified across the world
it is not following a linear
um path from one country to the other it
is popping up even amongst people who
cannot be able to um be safe to have
trouble anyway or come into contact with
someone else who are traveled so it
means that the way in which these
variants are actually traveling across
the world we cannot yet be able to
define it effectively and if we can't
define the pathway then close closure of
borders is not going to help um but it
is damaging our response in two very
important ways
one is that it is going to discourage
countries from
um doing any full genome sequencing and
sharing their data that is damaging and
second economically speaking by starting
to label countries as sources of
different types of or variants
we are going to start affecting
not only response of the public to
vaccination but also the economic
damage that is going to be caused is
going to be more if we deal with this as
we are dealing with variants and not
parts of the world then we are going to
be a lot more effective but
travel bans do not work have never
worked are not going to work with this
variant or any other that will come up
in the future dr gurdasani what is your
opinion on this are the travel brands
premature an overreaction or or what's
your take on it
so by the time a paint is identified it
is widespread so you know when it was
identified many of us said yes it's
definitely here in england because of
the transport links between different
regions that doesn't mean that slowing
down import
doesn't help i mean certainly that helps
but not through travel bans through uh
screening at the border and strong
quarantined measures and not targeted at
single countries but rather
comprehensive ones that require
isolation and testing of all travelers
and those measures have been shown to be
highly effective in in very large
studies across many countries but also
with the caveat that they are effective
because you're going to slow down spread
but then are you going to do something
with that extra time that you gain
because ultimately cases will probably
come through unless you have sort of
very blanket restrictions like some
countries in the southeast have which
have kept variants out
and i don't see countries like the us
and uk doing very much else with that
time and that time needs to be urgently
used to
put in domestic measures that reduce
transmission to reduce existing case
ways to build healthcare capacity to
increase vaccination and boosting unless
that time is used to do that it's it's
sort of going to be wasted
so i'll ask you the question that we put
at the top of the show and
is this going to be the new normal dr
gurdasani should people continue to
expect travel bans uh i know that um
ahmadougwel oma doesn't necessarily
agree with them but should people be
expecting this to be their new normal
they should face travel bans every
couple of months because of the
coronavirus
i think it depends on the political will
i mean if there is a globally
coordinated effort towards elimination
then things like quarantines and travel
restrictions and other restrictions will
be in the shorter term
but and by shorter term i still mean
unfortunately
over the course of a few years you know
like we did with measles we eliminated
it but gradually
but if that's not the course that we're
choosing and if the course is living
with the virus then i'm afraid we're
dealing with longer-term restrictions so
paradoxically i find the focus on
short-term freedoms and short-term
economic grain gains has trumped the
science which means that we are living
in longer-term restrictions and much
much greater economic damage and i think
at this point it's time for politicians
and scientists to reflect on you know
can we make a globally coordinated
effort which requires short-term pain
but you know does not require us living
with a virus that's constantly mutating
to potentially become more transmissible
and more able to escape the tools that
we have so michael jacobs how do then
governments balance keeping their
economies afloat on one end
while protecting populations from
transmission and is there a strategy
this time around going to have to be
different than last time around
the strategies in countries that are
more vaccinated um
is different um so lockdowns are
are occurring less than they used to
although we've now seen new lockdowns in
certain european countries because
transmission has extended far enough but
that will be different in many countries
from before i think many industries have
become better at adapting to the
situation where people can work from
home people obviously got used to that
in other sectors we've got better um
logistics which have kept people apart
from one another better ventilation of
uh of buildings and so on so
between industry and government we've
seen some forms of adaptation which have
meant that the economic costs
have not been as great but then
if we don't uh succeed in vaccinating
very large numbers of the population
globally and not just in certain
countries and these things
won't be fully effective it's a very
difficult choices for governments
because the economic costs are very
considerable you have obviously the
direct health costs of people getting
the disease um but you have huge
economic costs from making it more
difficult for people to work and to
consume and to produce and those have
real health costs themselves people
become ill
people are poorer then they can't access
healthcare themselves and so on so this
is a very difficult balancing act and
there aren't simple solutions
so what you're saying is that economic
inequality will worsen then michael
jacobs if if the situation continues as
is
economic inequality will worsen under
either leaving the the pandemic to go
its own way or
restricting the economy
much more deeply neither choice is good
for poor people because poor people have
fewer options always and so yes
inequality is likely to rise this is why
it's so important that governments um uh
extend the vaccination programs
particularly in the donation of vaccines
from rich countries to poorer countries
because in the end that is the only way
we will get a control of this and the
only way we can find some degree of
equitable uh outcome uh and i just want
to say about travel bans uh um
any form of travel restriction is an
economic cost to the countries involved
in that uh travel so even if you don't
ban people if you quarantine them if you
force them to have tests which they have
to pay for you will have a restriction
on the amount of travel that is unafraid
inevitable in a pandemic that travels
so quickly across borders so whether or
not it's actual bands or whether it's
just better
quarantining vaccination testing
processes that will impact on travel
with an economic cost
to what extent do you think this crisis
uh this pandemic has really been a
revelation on on weaknesses that exist
and how we all uh live together
absolutely and in fact
the weaknesses have been across board um
all types of communities and countries
all types of uh
strata and as far as uh social uh strata
is concerned
all of us have been exposed
in different ways now two things i like
to add to that
one is
um we do have tools at our disposal that
we need to use to slow this down so that
we can be able to perform um
adequate economic activities
one is testing we have rapid tests now
which give you results in a matter of
minutes and we need to use these more
effectively so that we can be able to
identify hot spots quickly and
put out
the spread as fast as possible before it
goes into other parts of the county
other parts of the world so effective
testing needs to be ramped up second is
vaccination
we need to vaccinate that way we can
reduce the number of people who are
going to be seriously ill and therefore
put less pressure on our health systems
and also have fewer people who can be
able to
spread the virus
more efficiently and finally is
information human beings by and large if
they're given correct information they
tend to react in a positive way they'll
always be that part of society that will
not be able to react in a positive way
the way that we transmit that
information how fast we do it and how
effectively it reaches the population is
critical in ensuring that the population
is
with
those who are responsible for guiding
and coordinating
right for this response and uh currently
we are not doing enough of providing
that information and we need to do it
more effectively okay on that note we'll
leave it there thank you so much for
joining us dr deepti gurdasani dr ahmad
dogwell oma and michael jacobs we
appreciate your time
thanks for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website aljazeera.com for further
discussion you can go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story you can join the
conversation on twitter our handle is aj
inside story from myself and the whole
team here in delhi thanks for watching
bye for now
[Music]
you